arturo encontró cuatro canicas y las
agregó a las cinco canicas que ya traía
en el bolsillo más tarde participó en
una competencia con sus amigos en donde
triplicó
sus canicas escribe una expresión
numérica que modele esta situación sin
realizar operaciones bien observemos qué
es lo que tenemos nos dicen que arturo
ya traía cinco canicas en su bolsillo y
agregó cuatro que se encontró entonces
agregamos las cuatro las sumamos y esto
que tenemos aquí es la expresión que se
refiere a la primera frase traía cinco
canicas y agregó cuatro que se encontró
cuatro cinco más tarde participó en una
competencia con sus amigos en donde
triplicó sus canicas entonces estas son
las canicas que arturo traía y en la
competencia las triplicó para triplicar
esto lo que tenemos que hacer es tomar
esto que son las canicas que ya tenía
arturo y ahora las vamos a triplicar
o sea tres veces las que ya tenía y esta
es la expresión numérica que nos están
solicitando bueno también podríamos
hacer las cuentas claro no no lo están
solicitando hagamos las 45 es 9 y 3
veces 9 es 27 bien ya tenemos una
expresión numérica que modela esta
situación sin realizar operaciones hasta
pronto